nicole kidman is an instant meme after
this photo of her looking shocked that
the 2022 oscars went viral very exciting
some fans were initially convinced the
australian actress's reaction was caught
when will smith made this controversial
moment happen oh richard
oh wow
wow
[Applause]
will smith
yup that's the king richard star
slapping chris rock after he made a
crack about his wife jada pinkett
smith's shaved head but it turns out the
image of nicole was actually taken
before the award show even began the
photographer from the los angeles times
who snapped the pic told vulture that
nicole was actually reacting to seeing
jessica chastain
i'm not the person who shows up and goes
oh it's me telling the outlet quote it
appeared that she was excited to see
jessica chastain across the room kidman
then reached out her arms and waved to
her with both hands
which created this iconic moment
instantly making nicole the meme worthy
queen she is
one fan tweeted alongside the pic it
isn't the hashtag oscars until we have a
truly insane nicole kidman reaction
image another says nicole kidman and
hashtag oscars equals a match made in
meme heaven wow i'm still around as for
why she's a match made in meme heaven at
the oscars in 2017 fans quickly called
out how she was clapping at the ceremony
nicole even revealed to an australian
radio show the story behind the famous
clap it was really awkward and i was
like gosh i want to clap i don't want to
not be clapping which would be worse
right yeah why isn't nicole clapping
flash forward to 2022 and nicole still
shares the same excitement attending
hollywood's biggest night the mulan
rouge star was nominated for best
actress for her role as lucille ball in
being the ricardo's but nicole
ultimately lost out to jessica who won
for the eyes of tammy fay thank you oh
my gosh you guys
okay
that's nicole proudly cheering on her
friend who ahead of the ceremony had
nothing but praise for her fellow
nominees these women
and their performances and also just to
be here
and i think we all know
what it takes to do this work
and so it's just like
it's like you're invited to the ball and
you go thank you
thanks for having me as for jessica the
actress shares the same girl power
mentality with the ladies
first of all the category i'm in with
nicole and olivia and kristen and
penelope
i mean these women are phenomenal we've
all spoken during this experience you
sent them flowers correct yes but also
nicole sammy champagne like we all face
it's like the most incredible group of
women and chris and i've been text it's
just so special so i
am excited to just be here and celebrate
with these women
[Music]